[Musique]
grand-père qui était sur Paris dans la
banque et qui a quitté la banque pour
venir planter ses premiers plomiers se
risier ici à vil donc voilà et puis là
c'est la 3è puis bientôt la 4e
génération qui arrive abricot pêche
nectarine ceris prune et puis deè partie
pomme et poir en pomme on est arrivé à
variétés et puis on est à une bonne
quinzaine aussi en variété d'abricot
aussi on est en bio sur toute la partie
donc pépin c'est pomme et poir et puis
bah à voir là dans les années qui
viennent pour passer la partie noyau
aussi en bio parce qu'on fait pourin
dire pas de traitement sur fruits donc
je pense qu'il a on est sur la bonne sur
la bonne voie et c'est facile enfin ça
semble facile à faire aussi en fou à
noyau mais après il existe les
insecticides mais bon après quand on
vend notre production à nos clients qui
sont en face de nous au quotidien bien
on n'est pas on penche pas pour cette
version là en
fait nos produits on les trouve l'hiver
forcément les pommes et poires c'est
plutôt sur les biocops les léopols sur
la région de Poitier après bah le la
biocope de
châeler ensuite on fait le marché
notutredame tous les samedis matin à
Poitier et puis après on fait une vente
aussi exclusive à l'exploitation toute
l'année en fait on ouvert pratiquement
toute l'année donc où on vend au détail
et on fait aussi du self cueillette en
pomme à l'automne en fait donc les gens
peuvent venir cuillir leurs pommes
directement dans le verger et après on
travaille
avec des petits magasins de producteurs
il y en a un à richolieu il y en a aussi
à bfond la ferme de Belfond et puis
aussi donc le drive fermier via le la
Chambre d'Agriculture les abricoss on
travaille avec le local avec plusieurs
restaurants la belle étoile à vuil
qui font des desserts à baseabricot puis
après au mois d'aût ils vont refire à
base de nectarine de
pêche les pommes bio coûte plus cher à
produire donc on essaie de d'en perdre
le le moins possible donc bah jus de Pom
on a toujours fait on a diversifié en
faisant un peu de compote maintenant et
des enfin des purées de de pommes
compotte pommes fraises on essaie de
diversifier un peu les les les
productions à côté de à côté de la pomme
classique en fait ou de chez vous donc
si vous voulez venir chercher des fruits
n'hésitez pas nous sommes là et pour
vous servir et vous
contenter